- [Announcer] Icon!
(epic music)
Legend!
All-time great!
(crowd cheering)
Garth Brooks is simply put:
one of the most successful
recording artist
and performers in history.
(crowd cheering)
Born in Tulsa Oklahoma,
Garth got his start singing
in dive bars and clubs
before releasing his first album in 1989.
That album was just the beginning
as Garth would go on to become
the best-selling solo artist of all time
with over 148 million albums sold.
His generational talent helped make Garth
the only artist in
music history to receive
seven diamond album awards
which commemorate over 10
million in sales for each album.
Blending country music,
a rock and roll flare,
and captivating storytelling,
Garth is known world-wide
for his stunning live shows.
A unique mix of the intimate,
the spectacular,
and above all, an unmatched
gratitude for his fans.
(emotional music)
He remains the only artist to win
seven CMA entertainer of the year awards
and he continues to sell out
shows all over the world.
Garth Brooks is undeniably
a living legend.
And the best part is,
he shows no sign of slowing down y'all.
His legacy only continues to grow.
(crowd cheering)
- So,
first of all
I think that this is
the greatest idea ever
because what I'm obsessed with vinyl.
And also you're like the
smartest businessman ever,
because you can't get your music in a rest
so this is amazing!
Because we're all gonna get it!
(clapping and cheering)
So why did you decide
to release it on vinyl?
- Well you know the weird thing was we
you know, we went over
and raise our babies,
but when we came back,
vinyl was coming back.
And you got to be kidding me, right?
And it's so cool, but then you start
to look at pieces, right?
So you collect vinyl,
- Yes.
- You know they cost 29 bucks,
39 for a piece of vinyl!
- Yeah.
- So we got with a company that
had plans all over the world
and said, "make me a box if you can
where people can pick
it up for a great cost".
It doesn't cost, but Morgan
should have the whole
collection, so here it comes.
All our stuff on vinyl for the first time
and I gotta tell ya,
we have turn table at home
and I just played this album, which is
one of my dearest babies right here, but
just played it on there
and it all just comes back
to the very first time you heard it.
- Ain't that amazing?
(cheering and clapping)
That's what I love about vinyl.
- Something about it, I
don't know what it is.
- I think it's so great that
you're doing it 'cause I think
I saw you in Vegas, your
residency and I was blown away
because I missed, I was telling
the audience earlier I was
so poor as a kid, I
couldn't go to any concert.
So I never got to,
everybody from school would
came back with all the
merch, and the T-shirts
it would be like, "and another
awesome concert I missed!"
So like, "Cool!"
But like, it was one of those
things when I got to see you
in Vegas, it was almost better
because it was just you and your guitar,
- Yes ma'am
- and you were like, the
greatest storyteller ever.
- That's really sweet.
- I was captivated the entire,
I only use the word captivated
when describing Meryl Streep,
this is a big moment for me.
- Wow, thank you very much.
(audience laughing)
- But no! I'm just saying like, I
was captivated the entire time!
I was looking at Reba
and Narvel over together
and I was like, "What is
happening!? He's got his guitar
and he's just covering all this
and just telling stories about it
and the songs that you love,
'cause you love covering music as well.
- Yes ma'am.
- It was the most amazing thing I've seen.
I think you were the most talented,
down to earth, like cool guy.
- Thank you.
(clapping)
You know what?
I'm gonna send you a big ass box
of all the T-shirts and
all the merch that we had
during those shows,
- You know what? Don't you
threaten me with a good time,
right Collins?
- I will.
(Kelly laughing)
I'll send it to ya, so you can catch up.